les frères bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france alors
lieu qui à annuler la condamnation
d'apple qu'est ce qui a motivé cette
décision selon vous alors cette décision
est extrêmement importante parce
qu'elles montrent que la cour de justice
de l'union européenne qui est le clé de
voûte du système juridique européen en
fait valide l'évasion fiscale c'est
quand même quelque chose de fondamental
c'est un problème très important puisque
au niveau de la france ça représente 81
milliard d'euros d'évasion fiscale donc
le déficit budgétaire de la france selon
hilia noulette l'ancien président du
parquet national fille et financier et
on sait que les multinationales en fait
se débrouille pour loger toutes leurs
recettes fiscales dans des paradis
fiscaux il y en a 5 au niveau de l'union
européenne dont 3 systémique le
luxembourg l'irlande et les pays-bas
malte et chypre etc
or apple en fait faisait 4 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires en france
est déclarée 13 millions de résultat net
alors qu'en fait si on regarde le
résultat d'être mondiale on voit que le
résultat net réel était de 800 millions
d'euros
la commission européenne n'a pas
contesté le fait que apple siphonne tous
ces résultats de tous les pays européens
pour les placer au lieu au en irlande
c'est très important de le dire elle
avait validé cette évasion fiscale dans
la commission européenne par contre a
dit que apple devait payer le un taudis
est ce normal en irlande
quand elle siphonne les recettes
fiscales françaises allemandes et c'est
un taux de 12 et demi pour cent or apple
a payé un taux de 0 005 % quasiment rien
et la cour de justice de l'union
européenne donc la clé de voûte du
système juridique européen vient de dire
que tout ça n'est pas anormal avec des
arguments un petit peu scabreux voilà
c'est tout à fait étonnant comprends pas
cette décision
enfin cette décision valide complètement
l'évasion fiscale d'apple effet que
personne ne peut lutter contre cela dans
l'union européenne
alors on l'a vu un sur les images
plusieurs grosses entreprises du
numérique ont déjà été condamné pour des
motifs divers
quels sont aujourd'hui les rapports
entre lieux et les gars femmes en fait
les gars femmes font un peu la loi
puisque on a laissé contrairement russo
chinois il ya d'autres pays qui ont
développé leurs propres systèmes
numériques leur propre cas femmes
en fait l'union européenne a laissé tous
les gars femmes pénétrer l'europe et on
a plus de souveraineté juridique mais en
face qui est fondamental ici c'est le
problème d'évasion fiscale puisque ça
coûte des recettes fondamental à
l'europe et on voit que l'europe est en
incapacité d'agir en fait les propres
traités européens empêchent d'agir sur
l'évasion fiscale et la clé le système
juridique empêchent d'agir parce que les
traités de l'union européenne ne nous
permettent pas d'agir puisque en fait
pour changer les règles fiscales
il faudrait l'accord unanime de tous les
pays pour changer les traités européens
il faut l'accord unanime de tous les
pays et le luxembourg l'irlande vives de
l'évasion fiscale du pillage fiscales
des états europe d'être des autres états
européens et donc à partir de ce moment
là on ne peut absolument rien faire
puisque ils n'accepteront jamais leur
ruine en votant pour que l'union
européenne ait un poids sur la fiscalité
et puisse changer la fiscalité
la dernière question parle ici d'évasion
fiscale 1 quel est le manque à gagner
justement pour les membres de l'union
européenne
alors le manque à gagner total je le
connais pas quand je connais juste parce
que c'est que des estimations
l'estimation du parquet national
financier la présidente c'était 80
milliard d'euros qui recoupe d'autres
estimations
il faut dire que c'est extrêmement grave
parce que en fait on se retrouve
du fait de l'évasion fiscale dégâts
femmes et de toutes les multinationales
ans puisque même les multinationales
françaises très souvent font de
l'évasion fiscale eh bien les personnes
les entreprises honnêtes et les gens
honnêtes qui déclare que le correctement
leurs impôts se retrouvent à payer plus
d'impôts et en fait quand on réfléchisse
à des conséquences absolument
gigantesque puisque derrière c'est aussi
de l'austérité pour les services publics
en france et dans toute l'europe
pour l'hôpital si l'hôpital est détruit
c'est à cause de cette austérité et du
manque à gagner notamment des recettes
fiscales donc on voit que ce vol à
grande échelle est quasiment criminelle
merci beaucoup à philippe maurer d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste